do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 video as you all know the night king
and his army are basically just moments
away from arriving at Winterfell for the
biggest battle in Game of Thrones
history according to Daenerys Targaryen
she thinks the night king has around a
hundred thousand White's in his army we
also know he has several White Walkers
and Giants in his army as well but his
most dangerous weapon has to be his
dragon now that the night king has his
own dragon he has the ability to kill
large groups of soldiers within the
matter of seconds now although Daenerys
Targaryen still has two dragons of her
own this creates a major issue for
everyone at Winterfell
stopping the night King's dragon has to
be one of their top priorities
unfortunately this will not be an easy
task not only is it very hard to hit a
moving target but this moving target
also happens to be incredibly fast it
almost seems as if the dragon became
faster after the night king resurrected
it they will also have to try to take
down the dragon in the middle of the
night when their visibility is at its
lowest so it should be very interesting
to see how they kill Viserion what kind
of weapons do you need to kill this kind
of a dragon thankfully we now know
exactly what kind of dragon Viserion is
for those of you that don't know
vissarion is a white Walker dragon this
was confirmed by the director of the
season 7 finale he talked about this
during an interview right after season 7
had ended you see the night King
resurrected the dragon by physically
touching it just like we saw the night
king do when he turned when it crashed
her son's into a white Walker this means
it will be even harder to kill vissarion
because White Walkers are much harder to
kill than your average white now I know
there are still many fans that do not
know the difference between whites and
white walkers for those of you that
don't know the whites make up the
majority of the night king's army they
are the dead soldiers the night King
resurrects by lifting up his arms as we
saw at hardhome these are basically his
foot soldiers most of them look like any
other dead soldier that has blue eyes
but some of them also look like
skeletons depending on how long they
were dead now we know the whites can be
killed by fire this has been
demonstrated ever since the very first
season we also know they can be killed
by dragonglass
this is one of the reasons why Jon Snow
needed so much dragonglass that's
because most of the night Kings Army is
made up of those whites now it also
looks like you can kill whites by using
Valyrian steel it did seem like John was
killing several whites by using Longclaw
last season so as you can see at least
in the television show it's fairly easy
to kill the night Kings whites now when
it comes to White Walkers it's not so
easy to kill them these are the night
Kings soldiers that were created from
Craster's sons they look very different
than the whites most of the White
Walkers do ride on horses and they have
very noticeable long white hair down to
their shoulders they're also known to
wear some body armor very similar to
what the knight King wears they also
have magical ice weapons like the knight
king since the NIE King did create them
by physically touching them they also
have some extra powers of their own the
White Walkers also have the ability to
raise the dead this was revealed when
Jon Snow killed a white Walker last
season when Jon Snow killed that white
Walker it also simultaneously killed all
the whites that were traveling with him
not only can White Walkers raise the
dead but they're also very strong and
incredibly fast they cannot be stopped
with regular weapons we have seen that
they are able to shatter steel swords
just by touching them we have also seen
just how much power they have this white
Walker was able to bitch-slap Samwell
Tarly into another dimension now the
good thing is we do know how to kill the
White Walkers
you can also kill white walkers by using
dragonglass weapons we saw this when
Samwell Tarly stabbed one right in the
back we also know that white walkers can
be killed by Valyrian steel Jon Snow has
demonstrated that several times now I do
not think white walkers can be killed by
fire when we see the night King attacked
the three-eyed Ravens cave we can see
the children of the forest try to
protect the entrance of the cave by
using fire that fire did stop the whites
as you can see they did not want to walk
through the fire because it would have
killed them but it did not stop the
night
King or the White Walkers they were able
to walk right through the fire we have
seen them do this many many times
so since Vasari on is a dragon and he is
a white Walker dragon you might not be
able to kill him with fire either now
you might be able to kill him with
dragon fire because as we all know
dragon fire is much different than
regular fire but there is no way to know
for sure until we see it put to the test
what we do know is you can kill White
Walkers by using dragon glass and
Valyrian steel we see these two weapons
work so since Viserion is a white Walker
dragon I am assuming you can kill him by
using dragon glass and Valyrian steel
too the only problem is Viserion will
most likely be flying around in the sky
during most of the battle
we know they have Valyrian steel swords
and a bunch of dragon glass daggers but
those are weapons you have to hold in
your hand they have to somehow get those
weapons into the sky to hit the dragon
so how do they do this
well Game of Thrones may have already
started to foreshadow this in some of
the trailers and maybe even in the first
episode in the first official trailer we
could see a mysterious character holding
a bow and arrow
they never did show that character's
face but ever since that trailer came
out we have started to see several
characters using bow and arrows again we
could see Arya Stark using a bow and
arrow in the very first episode of the
show then we saw her using it again when
she was traveling what the Brotherhood
without banners not only was she still
training with that weapon but she also
got some tips from one of the greatest
bowmen from the story which is angle I
the archer and release never hold he was
trying to tell Arya how to become even
more accurate with a bow then even as
recently as last season we heard Arya
tell Sansa the story about her shooting
the arrows when she was still a child
when the new trailer came out for the
second episode we could see Arya Stark
holding a bow again maybe this is all
leading up to a big moment like someone
taking down the Night Kings dragon also
when Arya went to see ginjury and the
Ford
we could see they were making
dragonglass arrowheads maybe those are
the dragonglass arrowheads that killed
the dragon
another thing we saw during that scene
was Aria heaven Gendry make her a new
weapon Aria gave him a design for a
weapon she wants him to have custom made
if you look at her sketch you can see
that weapon actually turns into two
different weapons it has a detachable
dragon glass dagger this has made me
wonder if ginjury knows how to turned
that weapon into a projectile the sketch
doesn't have many details but if that
weapon is spring-loaded then it might be
able to shoot that dragon glass dagger
something I mentioned in a recent video
was the weapon master for Game of
Thrones who makes all their weapons said
aurea's new weapon will be a showstopper
that made me think Aria has to do
something crazy with that weapon since
we have seen whites and white walkers
get killed many times already I do not
think that was what he was referring to
for me a showstopper would be getting to
see someone take the dragon out of the
sky or even killing the night king I
guess we'll just have to wait and see
what all that new weapon can actually do
let's stick to the bow and arrows for
now so we already know arias stark may
use a bow and arrow during the battle
but she isn't the only character we have
seen holding that type of weapon we have
also seen Theon Greyjoy holding a bow
and arrow of this season as well this
was one of the weapons he took with him
when he rescued his sister now in the
books
Theon is missing several fingers from
both of his hands but I guess they
aren't as bad in the show I thought
Theon may never be able to use a bow and
arrow again but it looks like he can use
one just fine
now some of you may or may not remember
this but Theon Greyjoy is actually an
excellent marksman with that weapon I
would even say it's his weapon of choice
Lords the Greyjoy's veins for their
skills at archery navigation and
lovemaking
now that we know Theon Greyjoy is
heading to Winterfell maybe he can be
the one that kills Viserion imagine if
he was actually the one to do this that
would certainly gain the respect from
some of the other characters killing
that dragon will be instrumental in
defeating the night king now there is
one other thing I do want to mention
about the young gradually as we all know
Theon basically held bran Stark as his
prisoner when he
winter fell back in the second season
that eventually led to winter felt
burning and brain stark having to flee
from the castle brandon Theon have not
seen each other since then it will be
very interesting to see these two
characters reunite after all this time I
think this could lead to Theon trying to
do something for bran
because he has to feel bad for what he
had done although Theon has already did
something for Sansa it was a brand that
had to witness Theon and his men start
to kill other characters in service of
House Stark
Theon taken Winterfell from bran
eventually led to the Starks completely
losing control of their castle for a
very long time now if you remember back
in the first season we saw Theon save
brain Stark's life by using his bow and
arrow I'm wondering if we can see Theon
do something like that again
just a kind of makeup for taking a
castle from bran since this final season
already has so many similarities to the
first season I could see something like
that happening as we all know Theon
should have died many different times
but they are keeping that character
alive for some reason now it's the final
season and he's on his way to Winterfell
right before the biggest battle in the
show's history this will be fianc final
moment to do something good in the eyes
of the entire north I think this has to
mean that Theon steps up and does
something pretty big now there is one
other character we saw holding a bow
this season that would be sir Bronn of
the Blackwater he was given the same
crossbow that killed Tywin Lannister we
already have good reason to believe that
bran will show up in Winterfell after
all that's where Circe's brothers are at
Qyburn said she wants her brother's dead
but I don't think bran will kill either
one of them however he can still show up
in time for the battle we also already
know that bran is very accurate with a
weapon like that we saw Bronn use a bow
and arrow when he ignited the Wildfire
during the battle at Blackwater Bay he
is also the only other character we have
seen hit a dragon besides the night king
when bran shot the arrow at dragon he
was basically using a giant crossbow
maybe the next time he tries this he can
actually kill the Night Kings dragon as
of right now I would say these are the
best options to killing Vasari on now I
know there are some other characters
that are known to use a bow and arrow
but we don't know how many of them are
coming back to Winterfell
however we
have already seen Aria Fiona and Braun
have abode this season and there is also
a good chance that all three of them are
at Winterfell during that battle I know
that some of you said maybe mirror Reid
can show up and use the bow and arrow
but there is no evidence of that
happening as of right now I just want to
talk about characters we have already
seen holding that weapon this season
there is something else we could see
kill the dragon during the trailer for
the second episode we could see there
are some trebuchet at Winterfell
these weapons do have the ability to
throw at a great distance I think they
could fill these up with razor sharp
dragon glass then just keep launching
them at the dragon over and over and
over again if you throw enough [ __ ] at
the wall eventually something will stick
now of course the simple answer might be
the right answer in order to kill the
Night Kings dragon you might just have
to use another dragon I have always
thought that made sense because of the
Dragons names drogon is named after
called Drago and Viserion is named after
Viserys since we know that Khal Drogo
killed Viserys back in the first season
then maybe we can see it happen again
only this time what the dragon's Drogo
may be the one to kill Vasari on that
would also be like another callback to
the first season the chances are this is
how the night Kings dragon dies but I do
like some of those other options let me
know how you think Viserion dies this
season do you think it could be arias
dark Theon Greyjoy saw Bronn of the
Blackwater or maybe you have another
option let me know your thoughts down
below in the comment section anyways I
want to thank everyone for watching the
video I really appreciate that and I
also want to thank everyone on patreon
for supporting the channel I hope you
all have a great day I will see you
again very soon bye
you
[Music]
[Music]
you